We're very privileged,
uh,
today and Wednesday to have my dear and good friend of 35 years standing Paulos
I noni who,
um,
has,
uh,
for quite a long time.
I've been a partner of Goldman Sachs and is indeed the second most senior member
of the Goldman Sachs partnership by age,
by age.
And today we're going to do it very informal class with facts on the slide sheet
as background.
Uh,
we're going to have Paolo,
uh,
talk about,
talk about how Goldman actually works at scene from the inside,
which will be a rare opportunity to see the most remarkable,
uh,
American business from,
from the interior,
which is,
it's truly a great opportunity for all of them.
And then on Wednesday,
uh,
Paolo,
we'll do a major European case managed by Goldman Sachs and a case which was in
progress when he was here a year ago and which has now come to a resolution.
The slide set for that is posted that will be a little more formal than today,
but still an informal,
informal in style.
Uh,
please help me welcome Paulo Sedona
[inaudible]
Paolo.
Um,
let's talk about you.
To begin with,
uh,
you are a northern rather than a southern Italian sent on us.
Yeah.
Yes.
Is there any significance in north south in Italy?
I think significantly.
Are there.
How many people of southern Italian descent in the room?
Sort of.
Ah,
okay.
What,
how would,
how do most northern Italians look on the look on that distinction?
Uh,
they look if that distinction like,
uh,
like this house was almost a colony.
I will queue by the or conquest in 1861 and a never really sort of conquered,
but I never really
simulate a simulator.
Yeah.
I,
the the north is the industrial and business heart of deadly.
Is that a fair statement?
The North say he's the most industrialized parts.
Yes.
But back in the styles you will have a tote.
The Heck I,
I've known we want to go into
the Italian political economic system,
but in the south you have certain areas that are,
but as a reasonably high level of interest,
I say,
uh,
how old are you came from?
You first arrived in the stage in what year?
1973.
And you came as a graduate student in the Yale Political Science Department.
I remember it well.
Paolo became an outstanding and touch football player
and too small for that.
No,
no,
you're really good at it.
And you even picked up the raw language of the game.
That's the head say size.
There is the,
uh,
and you left Yale.
He was 78 and 78 to go to work for Johnny and yelly yet Fiat.
Yeah.
Uh,
tell us a little about that.
Stemmed,
uh,
that's the [inaudible] I worked for.
I worked for the chairman of the board and also the owner of the controlling
stakes that fear to for about five or six years.
Right.
And after I became,
I wanted to do some,
uh,
some moral cooperation on experience.
And so I went to,
to manage the international business development department fit.
And in that capacity,
I spend about five years in Washington here because,
uh,
we had a chairman or Fiera USA because we had some issues with the,
with the then the US government and after I spent two years in Moscow in 1990
and 1991.
And,
and what were you looking at in Moscow?
In Moscow,
I was looking to acquire the largest,
uh,
lashon manufacturer of automobiles that,
the government,
uh,
first the government of the Soviet Union and second,
the government of this,
of the rational or a pub league when the Soviet Union wasn't dismembered or
these appeared,
uh,
and decide to buy that that was their company has been established by fear as a
wholly on,
uh,
company from all he owned by the Soviet state about 15 years earlier.
And so it goes based on peer technology and,
uh,
both Gorbachev first and yells and after would want you to pay that dies and
they will send out to taken by it.
And I'm success ultimately,
you ultimately walked away from the deal.
I understand that.
Yeah.
Or we walked away because it was an ordeal for the simple reason that the
management and the regional,
some are very,
John wanted to become owners of the factory
and,
uh,
and to have ownership of the asset and a 100% control on the pallets on the
cashflow.
And so they were definitely,
they were not,
they were not willing to sell it to a right to a foreign yet.
So that's a nonstarter.
Then after,
after the,
the,
uh,
stood in Russia,
I did a couple of years a more fee it and after I decide to join goal,
then you joined Goldman and you joined them as what,
what was your title at that time?
Is that time Goldman did not have managing director as opposed to Oh,
it only vice president,
sorry,
associate,
sorry.
I analyst associate and vice president of various degrees of seniority and uh,
I joined them as,
uh,
the last degree of vice president and after I became a managing director in nine
t seven and a partnering to Samson.
Okay.
And,
uh,
let's now turn to Goldman,
the,
I'm talking to these people now for a second.
You'll remember the stark contrast we've drawn between the ownership form,
uh,
of joint stock corporation,
publicly traded joint stock corporation on the one hand and a partnership on the
other.
Uh,
can somebody help us out by naming the two or three variables on which flows to
our most importantly different.
Okay,
I'll settle for one.
Variable
liability.
Okay.
Limited liability in the case of the Joint Stock Corporation.
Go ahead.
Another tall
a liquidity.
Liquidity.
Huge difference,
right?
You can't sell your partnership and Goldman
partnership income is not taxed separate.
Okay.
The partnership is invisible in the tax code so that the procedure reading give
you too.
Thank you.
Once ones get taxed,
the individuals of course get taxed.
Okay.
But it's in a set in effect,
shaved one layer of taxation.
Yes.
The,
the right or ability,
um,
to make management decisions.
Okay?
So that in the case of a partnership,
every one has management job.
All the partners have management jobs where as with a corporation you have
centralized management or the board appoints a chief,
uh,
chief executive and the chief executive,
at least in theory,
is responsible for appointing everyone else.
Uh,
and finally,
how did the two do as media for raising capital mechanisms for raising capital?
Uh,
back to tall,
uh,
a core joint stock corporation as much more scalable.
It's got greater scalability.
You can raise a lot more capital than a partnership.
Okay.
The joint stock corporation was created as a mechanism for gathering up capital
in very large quantities and it's good at now back to Paolo.
Historically Goldman was straight forwardly a partnership.
What's a partnership up to 1999 but you ever had a,
you ever read the case study with the IPL,
Goldman Sachs and um,
and it was an extraordinary partnership with an extraordinary record of success
in nearly all of its history.
Is that a fair statement?
You
mean the 99 with
it's a first date when there are a couple of exceptions?
Uh,
1929,
tough one.
A lot of people,
yes,
top and a lot of people,
uh,
especially tough,
almost killed the partnership.
Uh,
there is another section we choose which is interesting for your class vehicles.
Usually a investment bank and securities for pain to do badly tend to be very
cyclical and to do badly on the downturn.
And well from the op term there is one exception,
one exception of please just fire was born in Kurdistan,
which is very interesting.
Everybody else was doing very well in 1994 what Goldman was doing very badly.
And it almost killed the partnership as badly as a,
as badly,
as a 90,
almost as badly in 1928 and as badly as the crisis for a petty center and in
dairy zone.
The reason for that and that,
uh,
again,
you know,
mixed blessings,
one of the,
uh,
one of the facts of life there reason why Goldman was doing very badly was
because Goldman is as tried a very aggressively to do a proprietary trade,
especially in fixed income.
And,
uh,
that was not really part of the Goldman culture.
And,
uh,
the risk management in the trading,
the trading organization or Goldman was very bad.
And uh,
in 19,
toward the end of 1994,
the second half of 1994,
Goldman start having losses that at that time were staggered or especially for a
partnership and almost the Capitol,
the Capitol of the partnership was almost wiped down.
And actually that's where,
uh,
that's where the,
the,
where the firm had their American bull ability of select a group of leaders that
a new that came from trading new,
proprietary trading very well.
Even if some of them were not born in the same,
that same organization in way able to restructure the trading,
the trading philosophy and this special is the risk management function or
Goldman.
And probably one of the reason why Goldman has done not so badly on the created
Kranz is because of that whole level of uh,
the risk or risk management end of,
uh,
end of the trading
or mat style in control of the autonomy of the traders.
Okay.
Actually the two people that DDH,
one was [inaudible] who was the managing partner when the firm went public and
the other was Lloyd Blankfein who is a CEO today
and core design may be available shortly.
You could go to cam back to Goldman.
I'm kidding.
Haven't seen he wants to
move the just notice,
notice the style in which Paolo just said something.
He said
Boldman has done
fairly well in the current crisis now that's a huge understatement.
Goldman has blown the doors off.
The current crisis
end of 2008 wasn't the nice beard.
It was an ugly period.
But compared with all its competitors in this and in many other matters,
Goldman has been absolutely tops and part of the culture is not to sort of chest
thumping is not the Goldman style.
There's a very understated style that emerges a and which I think it bodies.
Um,
but now the move to a corporation corporate ownership for,
uh,
has an obvious upside in raising capital,
but an apparent downside in changing the incentives
for top management in a way that might at first blush seems likely to undermine
the cultural strengths of the historical partnership.
And why don't I shut up for quite a while now and let's get you talking about,
about how that has been accomplished and how it works.
And,
uh,
somewhere or another we ought to talk about how people are recruited to the
partnership and,
and to leadership roles in the firm and how that might relate to the style of
management that you,
that you get with [inaudible].
See,
I'm [inaudible] at you and I'm sure that at any bags course you're going to sit
and wait.
And parties in the case that I have read,
uh,
the two advantages of a partnership,
especially in the investment banking word and,
uh,
as securities for,
I mean,
my opinion,
one is that,
uh,
as,
as opposed to the joint stock corporation and which a diag the diag discuss with
you in a partnership.
Uh,
there is no split between management and ownership.
The owners of the capital of the firm are also the managers of the company.
And so that's,
that's accord,
creative set of incentive.
But by not distinguishing between provider of capitals in the,
uh,
in the end,
the people that have the control of the operation of the firm
in Goldman,
every generation of partners,
leaders have always been convenience.
The DDOS is a great advantage.
Uh,
the other adventure that you have is that,
uh,
and these are the an event,
especially in an investment bank in new securities firm,
which are people business,
they have no,
if you look at these,
if you look at these companies that are America ball in the amount of sales or
revenues that they have,
they have no fixed capital,
have no buildings.
Most of the building at least
they have no plant and equipment.
They have low patrons is just the people's business.
And so when you are rounding the People's business,
uh,
one of your core competencies has got to be the ability of coordinate the
behavior to those people.
So it's thousand 4,020 sounds and Goldman has always been convinced that the
partnership structure,
it's a idea to coordinate the behavior or the top echelon of the firm.
And so the real challenge that Goldman was facing when Goldman decided to go
public was to try to combine the advantages of the joint stock corporation,
especially in raising permanent capital.
Because the partnership capital is not permanent.
It's limited.
But if you are very successful,
the limitation or not so much on size as they are on the availability of their
capital for a long period of time,
because of course you can put a restriction on the partners on taking away the
capitol when they become limited.
But those restriction we'll just put along the,
the,
their ability to take capital out.
But the,
if not,
nobody would like to be a partner with the capital,
cannot be taken out.
Goldman tie to the Goldman,
the then leadership of Goldman and try to combine the advantages of the
partnership as far as having the owner management,
uh,
to get the owners,
managers manage the company and the ability to coordinate behavior.
So what Goldman tie to do,
and he's a unique form of corporate governance,
is a partnership that is also a joint stock company.
And so for instance,
the title of partner was not eliminated and Goldman built a structure in which
partners are rewarded and incentivized in a different way from the other
stockholders.
Uh,
the other thing that,
uh,
the other thing that goal and decided to do was,
which is unusual in joint stock company and you won't find it in any other
partnership that has become a joint stock company was to maintain the structure
or the uh,
selection of leadership.
I their selection of the partners almost as it was before it became a joint
stock company where maybe so what you have let me die.
Do what you have is that you have the legal form of a joint stock liability
company in imposed into an organization that as organizational structure and
institution of government except at the top as maintain the same institution and
the same type of leadership selection that you had in the partnership,
let's Say Partnership Pre Ipo.
Okay.
So let's talk about this leadership selection process.
Beginning getting with the entering classes of employees.
Usually uh,
usually when you enter and golden man you are given a class like you are given a
class.
When you went into,
Yay,
you are the class of
2007,
w w we,
we designate them by the year we designated by the year
in which they start.
And that there is some sort of course was an arm in wheat.
Uh,
you are generally considered for partnership once a year,
spent a fair amount of time and the firm and uh,
once uh,
you have been,
you've done a stint as a managing director
and uh,
what,
when your,
when your class is up for partnership.
Yeah.
How big are these classes?
More or less?
Depends.
But let's say that they are,
if you wonder what people,
500 maybe know a little less boring book,
a forum between 400 and 100.
It also depends on cause you know,
Eh,
the partnership had been [inaudible] it's not,
there is no ratio.
When we went public,
the partnership or the partners were about 210 years ago.
They were still lessons 303 years ago or four years ago.
Now there are more than four.
There will be a lot less in 2010.
Okay.
So
we've got these groups of a few hundred and uh,
a certain point.
It comes time.
It comes down to be considered it time for someone that has done that.
I've had a normal carrier.
It comes time to be
conceited.
And the way,
the way,
the way the selection works,
he's the partners of each division make oo or three,
least of all the candy that have their own division,
uh,
in a list B list and a c list.
The alias theories,
they're the best candidate.
There'd be least is the candy that are somewhere in between.
In the Sealys there's a candy that's,
that are not,
that do not have a lot of chances in that particular year.
The partnership selection every two years,
even years,
2000,
2002,
2004,
six,
eight,
10,
uh,
once these,
selection one,
this first selection has been done.
What the firm diocese takes a group of people and charge them with
the task of asking,
uh,
the community of mostly of the professionals about the candidates.
And so there are a group of people that,
uh,
conduct rigorous reasonably or eagers interview interviews,
Amanda,
everyone that has worked with everyone,
the large number of the people of the professional,
they've worked with the partners candidate,
be them more senior peers or more junior to try to gauge the quality of that
individual.
And even more the quality of that individual visa vi the girl that is being
considered as part of this is a process that it sounds easy,
but he's opposed says that takes about two months.
And if I remember our conversation correctly,
the from insists on people making pairwise comparison,
the firm in cs people make doing a qualitative analysis and after making a
ranking of everybody they know first,
second,
third,
fourth and fifth and in certain cases making pairwise when there are two
candidates that are in your similar position making pairwise comparison,
which is uh,
which is a nice,
which is an old way to do leadership selection because my understanding but it
might end up,
it's,
it's an understand ease that it was reasonably well used in the
Catholic church,
uh,
orders or in the well 11 century.
Right.
Actually there is someone that propose that in electing the pope,
the pope had to be elected doing pair.
Where pairwise comparison of the candidates,
well,
the Roman Catholic church is one of the few organizations with a more
distinguished administrative history that Goldman Sachs,
oh yeah.
I don't know.
I don't know one of the few,
but definitely.
So I think that Goldman consciously or unconsciously a copying some of the,
some of the,
at least some of the criteria used by the Catholic church.
As you listen to this,
think about what this process would do to your thinking if you were a junior
person at Goldman Sachs,
right?
This is all designed to shape and mold a certain kind of purse of persona and
management style.
Now what Mba mentioned behavior,
pardon and and behavior in New York,
you know,
day your business.
So you mentioned in our conversation this morning a,
an element of the process called cross roughing.
These Zicasso happening is the one that Jason Fire in the room
cross roughing.
Is it a bridge term?
I tried to find out about his six system.
We just noise.
They're not one bridge player in this room.
That's an interesting fact.
I think it,
lots of poker player here.
Um,
so what's cross roughing in this process is,
this is a process of uh,
a group of people selected to search about deploy.
He's the one that I've just described that search about the qualities of the
barriers of the candidates,
but the itch from the,
they're not in,
they're not getting the same image in their division,
but not in the same division.
They belong to another TV or where's he,
what are you looking at an organization you have to think about about the
organization.
I get to see a graphical,
sorry,
who apps that you have to think about the organization and to the main show.
Okay.
Vertical in Arizona,
if you take the divisions,
they are like the business.
The only thing you are a normal industrial organization and they caught
vertical.
If you take the partnership it Cathy Organization or its own.
So if you want to have a very effective organization you should have,
you should have a good blend.
And the two mics,
all horizontal,
horizontal cleavage is let's say,
and vertical ones.
So the way the selection to the partnership is done because of course you cannot
have a Google people that had 500 candy want a candy that you do it by division.
The first selection is done by division.
When you,
when you do the least the least are done by the division or afterward seems that
you can set and the people that will do the selection and not the gatekeeper
twin horizontal cleavage and in horizontal organization they got not those that,
that gates are not capped by people from the same division but they are capped
by people from another division because you are moved to a totally,
because you had moved to Arizona Organization.
Does that shoe coordinate the top of the values of vertical division?
So this is a way in part of checking the tendency of divisions to become yeah,
becoming silos.
Silos.
I heard last week a great expression for this for a frog at the bottom of the,
well the sky is very small
and that's certainly true in many organizations,
right?
Where people get into their little part and they're not seeing what other people
are seeing across other divisions.
Now Tony and having gone so fair amount fracture in my professional life,
both in an industrial organization,
in a partnership and a in uh,
any,
any investment bank that was a limited liability company.
When you get to a structure,
it is very difficult to me
to make a rational decision if the organization is mostly based on vertical
division because
it was the vertical logic limits to some extent,
not to some extent limits to a major extent
the horizontal movement of individuals.
Right.
And so you tend to consider them only on the vertical scale and went on the
contract.
You are trying to restructure the organization or Change Organization or reduce
the number or develop new business units.
You have to be able to cut across the vertical division because if not,
you're utilize your manpower badly and your give your people a limited set of
choice.
They can only move either up or down but not sideways or they move side was
becoming very diff and leave.
They move sideways becomes very difficult,
very difficult for the organization to follow new business opportunities because
those,
those tend to be latter is the increase in scope is not increasing depth.
The um,
sorry.
We tend to be,
we tend to become too abstract.
I'm sorry.
The,
uh,
what are the qualities that are most important to cultivate students'?
You've seen the 14 commandments in the case,
the business plans,
business principles stream from inside commandments seen from outside.
Um,
what,
what are we trying to achieve here in the,
the behavior of the partnership
and those who inspired to beat in the partnership.
What would be the top two or three qualities we're aiming for?
Perfect.
Eh,
are you using on a vote of the gooey?
Oh,
well the me and independence,
but without getting too,
uh,
independent,
without pushing the independent to some extreme that he getting disruptive
for the organization.
So if you want,
you would try to,
you try to strike a balance between independence,
creativity and conformity.
And historically,
I seen Goldman has
a premium to some extent on conformity versus creativity.
I think that there are a fair amount that are fair amount of,
uh,
of innovations in which Goldman has come second or third and other firms have
had,
have been a lot more creative or somewhat more creative.
So you try to strike that balance.
Uh,
and of course,
one of the characteristic of their balances,
the idea,
the idea and s to a very reasonably strict belief system or corporate culture.
How about chest thumping and the conspicuous display of wealth?
Chest stamping definitely is,
uh,
is out out.
You want to be a con speakers,
display of wells.
I would say consider the standard of the industry is not too bad,
but consider the standard of the industry.
If you look at it from,
if you look at it from a,
from the out from outside the industry,
it's hard to judge,
but a c need from the out season,
the from the inside at least it's frowned upon.
It's a,
it's not considered a actually sanctioned for sound cause Alex and decides that.
And it can actually,
if I'm not mistaken,
damage a Goldman career if you are sort of wildly ostentatious,
uh,
and pick up $10,000 restaurant taps and that sort of thing.
Yeah,
usually,
usually you usually don't do it twice.
Um,
so Goldman,
he's the APP,
let me think about for a moment,
uh,
about another character
within the limits,
within the limits of the idea.
And to a straight belief system and I know that two things seems seems a
contradiction.
It also pushes you to be entrepreneurial
because
the facto
partners around their own business unit
and
the levels of hierarchy
are very,
very,
very short.
Your organization is very flat
and one of the reasons why he's flat is in try to four tie to foster
interpreneur ship,
especially in the partners because see the business and we'd go and an AU pair
aid the industry in which Goldman.
Okay.
All right.
And you will see it.
I try to give some examples in the printout that you have changes very,
very quickly.
So for instance,
if you,
if you take a picture,
we don't,
we don't give those details for many,
many reasons.
One of which is as they change too often,
if you take the 36 they say 36 to 30 major business line of Goldman five years
ago,
they are not the same and what they are today.
So because the environment changes so fast that if you are,
if you steal,
tried to operate and maximize or be efficient in the business,
you own it.
Of yesterday or this morning.
Mostly you are.
So if you have a good manager,
maybe you are a better entrepreneur and you are missing new opportunities that
the changes in the environment creates.
So what the firm is trying to do is to have eh,
to have a global leaders that more or less think along similar lines are that
are able to capture new opportunities and you a new business line,
a steak.
Let's for instance,
I started to make some examples,
not we,
uh,
we are under of being tortured to uh,
who abstract.
Let's take for instance,
I'm sure that uh,
some of you,
most of you are familiar with the crisis of the savings and loan association in
the U or the end of the 1980s.
Before that crisis,
Goldman Sachs,
they have never done a real estate principal investment,
never didn't even own the building where they work
because
they thought that there was no
capabilities inside the firm or making investment.
Actually when the,
uh,
what was the national trust or whatever,
what was,
what was the trust that the federal garden GC,
yeah,
when they started,
when the ITC or at least the national straddle,
the federal,
uh,
federal owner of all the real estate property,
because if you're a member,
most of the most of the crisis or originated from the loans that the,
that the saving and loan association I've done,
especially with real estate development.
So of course they're the federal,
the federal authority that a federal authority that uh,
that ran that Randall that ran that a there,
sorry,
the men,
they've the bureaucrats in good sense.
I planned that,
I'll throw it.
He started selling a lot of idealistic,
cheap all over,
all over the United States.
And it was obvious that there was a business opportunity there,
but it was also obvious that Goldman didn't know anything how to do it because I
mean,
Ipos,
a raid,
defense,
trading of stock of loans,
yes.
But never real estate and exceedingly smart person who by the way happens to be
a Yale Grad of course,
all of the opportunity.
So the lack of capability and decided to form a partnership with someone that
knew a lot about real estate all over the United States and didn't have any
capital.
And Goldman starting buying real estate and real estate loans or themselves for,
for ourselves and for investors.
And uh,
the,
the massive investment,
a history of going money in real estate,
both real estate assets and real estate loans started them just because of the
opportunity,
because of the opportunity offered by these trust corporation that we're selling
a loud amount of real estate,
obviously very cheap in the end.
Uh,
the ability of one of the partners to see that there was an opportunity,
but the doing side inside the firm,
there was no capability and understanding which one was cheap and which one was
not cheap.
It seems to buy me these two are too expensive or what he would have been a bad
investment anyway.
And at the end of the partner that we had,
uh,
got tired,
made too much money and uh,
but he had transferred enough knowledge to the partners and we bought it out and
made a,
it made whiter.
The same is to,
is our huge private equity.
We,
when Dave joined the firm,
we didn't do much of private equity.
We did it on behalf of client.
We're advising them when they are buying or selling campus,
but we didn't do it on our own and the on the counter immediately after the
crisis of the 2000,
the Dr Khan crisis,
we started seeing an opportunity and starting seeing an opportunity that you are
going to make a lot more money if you need it on your own.
Then if you're,
if you advise Blackstone,
a lot of,
a lot of banks saw it aware.
These are very interesting.
I,
we've were,
I've forgotten a lot of bank saw it but they decided not to do it for one very
basic and valid reason.
The fact that if you do private equity,
you start competing with your clients and that is supposed to be the scene
number one in a service organization.
However,
the
Uber's of Goldman was such that Goldman believed that they were smart enough and
good enough to be able to manage the country.
So it was a conscious decision.
There was a debate.
I remember it because I was part of the debate.
I was not fat and fortunately we have the debate of going public,
but I was part of,
it was on the outside actually.
I was so at the we joke.
Yeah,
I was actually cheated because I thought I was going to be in the next
partnership and so the partnership was going public in [inaudible] 99 and I was
up for election in 2000 the big prize was for or smash through a limited.
So Ashley was good price as we are.
Yeah,
you are very good.
But I was part of the PAG that Tegrity one.
Can I get you to talk for a minute about how Goldman manages his relationship
with power in government and other other branches of society?
Not just in the stage were a one
is the,
and you have these caps days.
I think that investment banking is a business where culture is very important
and
all of you that uh,
that are going to be on Wednesday.
We'll see that when I speak about,
when I speak about,
uh,
email and days a takeover,
the financial variables are important.
But I will say the variables that determined the winning or losing sometime a
what we call soft soft variables that have little to do with pies and finance.
And for a global firm that operates in this business,
it is very,
very difficult if not impossible to be able to understand the complexities of
the business culture in which it operates.
So your best way,
your best way to,
uh,
to understand those complexities and to avoid the land mines that are in
different business culture is to get someone that knows that business culture of
that particular culture very well.
So you end up selecting the globe advisor in any nation in which you operate,
that have a very deep understanding of that particular business culture and can
guide you and your client.
So that,
uh,
so that,
so that particular,
so that particular card,
I want to give you an example that he's so if not we have to abstain.
I want to give you an example that it's a,
actually it's personnel to some extent.
Goldman was very late compared to the other firm in moving overseas
and a Goldman started having a small operation in London in [inaudible] 87 when
JP Morgan was big,
when Lehman was big,
when Mary was big,
married,
no married,
started a little later.
But definitely when Morgan Stanley was big and at one point that the problem
that uh,
uh,
that goal that the Goldman people send overseas phase was
how do we get
how we enlarge in New York without making too many states.
The usual traditional where you've American firms to do that was to send
investment bankers from the U S and waited until they learn the various culture.
Very smart banker at Goldman who,
by the way,
he's one of the first graduate of these SOM Johnson.
When he had the responsibility of Europe.
He said,
the reason why I know it,
and I say it's personal because that the way in which I go to her coat it,
he said,
wait a second here we have to do something totally different.
We have to select for every nation where we operate.
Someone that maybe is not a banker,
who cares,
but that knows that business culture very well.
And so we had a generation of lateral hires,
me,
my colleague in France,
one in Spain,
one in Germany,
one in England,
one in Ireland,
one in Sweden.
None of them came from investment banking.
Very few of them came from banking.
My French colleague came from the state
and when I,
when I did my interview with John Zorn phone for a set of selection,
I said,
he said,
what would you say?
What did I do do?
I said,
how can I think about going in investment banking?
I can't even count.
I can't count now.
I can't balance a checkbook is a tool to say,
oh,
we can.
He said,
don't worry.
We have hundreds of people that can do that and we will give you a smart VP that
knows everything about investment bank,
but can you operate in the Italian business environment?
I say,
I said,
yes,
I think so.
Uh,
do you,
and we want to have 20 clients no more.
I need to have the 15 colors.
You can always clients we want and which we don't.
And I say,
I think so.
And he said,
do you know the way the client,
we want to pair eight inside as I think so.
It's okay.
Who cares if you can't balance a checkbook?
That Goldman became the first,
the first investment bank in Europe on 94th and 97 three years when in 90 in 90
sleep eat as well below everybody else.
And it is due to that particular career TBT of John [inaudible] who saw it
clearly has at least these are cultural business.
How can I send an American or a,
you need them.
They don't even speak the language now or in France.
They,
they,
I mean,
how can you go?
Have you ever tried?
We deal in France or in Spain.
Even for someone that has had some sort of,
uh,
exposure to different business culture lies like myself.
Ah,
I will never be able to do it like someone else would like to try to do and to
do it in Eaton.
Tried to understand how fear works while Anal sinks or out [inaudible] so when
in the,
in the context of the state,
uh,
you said a
beaten up Dartmouth linebacker.
Yeah.
Washington.
No hand cores locked down their story about hankies.
He has always been a republican.
Okay.
You want to,
you want to give you a little limitation of his voice style photo?
No,
he's a boy.
Boy's style was there even station,
oh no.
Going good to be his nurse
at three o'clock in the morning.
So,
you know,
Hank has always been,
there,
has always been very public.
He,
if you talk to him,
he ascribed these success at Goldman with the fact that he didn't know what to
do when he got out of the Harvard business school and he went to work for the
Nixon White House in the domestic affairs division.
And he finds himself at 24,
25 immediately afterward of gay.
And everybody above him is either in jail or a head toward resigned.
So he becomes the most senior person in that,
uh,
the more senior person in that,
in that department.
And he has to deal with the CEO.
He has to deal for a year and a half with,
uh,
with the CEOs of large corporation and a in Elan's.
And at the end he decided he doesn't like the government and uh,
he tries to get a job at Goldman and he gets fired.
And what he was always standing,
we'll say,
see,
the real skill that I had was not what they taught me at the Harvard business
school,
but the fact that I spent a year and a house in interacting with CEO and CFOs
from the largest corporation because I was at the White House and there was
nobody who was more senior than me.
Okay.
No,
he wasn't he.
And so he had been
Bush.
All right,
we'll get him to be the secretary of the Treasury,
my knowledge,
which is limited at least why before you accept.
Yeah.
And at one point he decided that,
uh,
it was tying to let a blank find,
do the chairman.
That was a perfect agency.
Okay.
Last question for today.
Oh,
simple observation would be that Goldman has essentially better,
better life on the quality of people.
Josh,
meaning all the things you're talking about plus something to do with just sheer
mental horsepower.
Smart people.
Oh,
he is a proud dad.
There is a reasonable amount of smart,
uh,
wait.
Don't overstay Paul though.
He's a reasonable amount of smart people by going to,
do you know what the characteristic,
you know what I mean?
Everybody who goes to an ivy league school with know it,
determination,
it's almost losing four then there's brainpower and definitely Goldman
definitely you will not
get a chance.
They'll even it becoming a VP north,
a partner if you are no determined.
The associate and the analyst working a hundred hour per week for years,
for five years,
seven years,
10 years.
The partner's work 70 or 80 hours per week until they write that.
Unless you are ready to do that.
No Way.
And if the phone rings the phone,
I told you a Hank,
Hank was,
he used to,
when he was a chairman,
Hank was used to listen to voicemail because now we communicate via email.
Then we communicate only via voicemail
in a firm that was,
that had uh,
what,
25 billion in revenues.
You could leave a voicemail for Hank Paulson and unless he was on a plane,
you've got an answer in less than five hours.
And if he was on a plane,
it depends how long the flight was.
15 hours.
You've got your answer after 59 terrific.
So please review the slides for Wednesday,
and let's think,
Carlo for this
very.